in this video you're going to be
preparing for the geometry midterm exam
with this giant review we're going to be
going through a number of different
types of questions a number of different
types of examples so let's jump into
this video and if you want to go to a
particular problem or type of problem go
to the description below I've got
timestamps there that'll take you right
to that type of problem so you can focus
on that concept but let's go through
these one by one here so the first
question says name the intersection of
plain o and plain P okay so remember a
plane is a flat surface right and we're
trying to find the intersection
basically what they share in common or
where they cross so let's see so when we
look at this plane here what's the
intersection of this horizontal plane
and this vertical plane well if you take
a look you can see that they're actually
crossing at this line right here and you
could label this line as line GF line D
F line FG and so on but basically when
you have two planes that intersect
they're going to cross that a line so
I'm just going to call this line D F and
you want to put that line symbol above
it to indicate that it's a line and add
a segment because remember planes keep
going you know in two dimensions like
that okay now Part B says name one pair
of opposite rays now this is like a
typical question a lot of students get
this incorrect and when you label
opposite rays what you want is you want
to have the same endpoint now when you
think of an endpoint an endpoint you can
basically like a starting point and it
goes one direction like a ray of
sunshine it heads out from that point
but opposite rays they have the same
endpoint but they're going 180 degrees
opposite direction so together they form
a line so we look at this diagram do you
see a pair of opposite rays well we've
got a couple of different options one
option would be like Ray da and rady B
or we could say Ray DC and Ray de or
radii and Ray de but the key point here
is you don't want to have the Rays going
like this so this is a kind of mistake
that students will make they'll look at
one ray like this one ray like this or
say for example you have a line and
they'll say I'm going to use this
endpoint I'm going to go this direction
I'm going to use this endpoint and I'm
going to glow that direction so they're
overlapping they don't have that same
initial starting point so in this
example there's a lot of right answers
but I'm just going to say
rady f & r a DG and also notice that the
Ray is always pointing to the right even
though the de ray might be going to the
left in the diagram this is just the
notation so you can see this is the
starting point D and then it heads
towards a and keeps going here at starts
that D has towards G and keeps going so
let's go to question number two now what
you might want to do is some of these
questions is see if you can do them on
your own
you know pause the video and then we can
go through them together so you can kind
of see if you're on the right track if
you're understanding the concepts so it
says if W y equals 18
so this whole length right here is 18
and X Y is 6 right here find W X now
whenever they say W X like that without
it you know a bar over it that means the
length of W X okay so saying what's the
distance from W to X let's label this
here so we have X Y is 6 we know that
this whole length right here is 18 so
what do you think the length of W X is
well if you said 12 you're absolutely
right and this is testing us on what
they call the segment addition postulate
so second edition postulate means that
the two segments add up to the length of
the whole segment very important when
you get into your geometry proofs okay
so now question number three says given
the segment MN with M has the
coordinates 2 7 and n has the
coordinates of 7 19 find the midpoint of
segment MN ok well Part B says the
length of MN okay so two different
things that they're testing us on and
these are very important questions one
is basically testing us on the midpoint
formula with the length it's actually
testing us on the distance formula so
let me write down those formulas here
for us so we can analyze them a little
bit further so midpoint what you're
doing is you're adding the x-coordinates
up and you're dividing by two and you're
adding the y-coordinates together and
dividing by two whereas for the distance
formula you're taking the square root of
the difference in the x-coordinates
squared plus the difference in the
y-coordinates squared then you add them
together and take the square root so in
this case what I'm going to do with the
midpoint is I'm going to take two plus
seven so I'm adding the x-coordinates
that's nine divided by two which is four
point five and if we add the Y's
together seven plus 19 is 26 divided by
two
is 13 so that's going to be the halfway
point the midpoint but if we want to
find the length
okay the distance between these two now
we're going to be subtracting the axes
so I'm going to say 7 minus 2 which is 5
squared and then I'm going to say 19
minus 7 which is 12 squared add those
together and take the square root now 5
squared is 25 12 squared we know is 144
if we add those together we get the
square root of 169 which is equal to a
length of 13 and you've got it so again
review your midpoint and distance
formula ok question number 4 they give
us this diagram here and it says
classify the angles so the first one
says classify angle a OD now remember
when you write an angle the middle
letter is the vertex that's the hinge of
the angle so we've got angle a o D now
notice how this is forming a straight
line this is actually called a straight
angle so I'm just going to write
straight okay now letter B says angle fo
a so let's trace that out so f 202 a now
remember again that little middle letter
is a hinge that's the vertex of the
angle but notice that that angle is less
than 90 degrees so we call that in acute
angle right cute and then letter C angle
AOB so where as a OB e o B okay so if we
trace that out we can see that one's
more than 90 degrees we call that an
obtuse angle old btus c and then the
last one says angle fo D and let's see
where angle F OD is we've got F oh D and
you can see again that also is greater
than 90 degrees that's going to be
obtuse notice this box right here this
square that indicates the angle zod is a
right angle or 90 degrees but in this
case f OD is greater than 90 so again we
have another obtuse angle okay so that's
classifying angles now number five they
give us this diagram here and it says
find the measure of angle yxz so where
is y XZ y - x 2z so we're trying to find
out the measure of that angle
but the thing you notice here is that
see how wxz see how that forms a
straight line okay that's a straight
angle these two angles here are called a
linear pair pair means two linear means
they form a line and we know that when
they form a line that's 180 degrees so
if we add these two angles together
that's going to add up to 180 degrees so
that'll allow us to solve for X now one
mistake that students often make when
they're doing these problems they get
caught up in the algebra I don't know if
this happens to you at all but you know
when you're solving this okay I'm just
going through this you can see that X is
equal to how much 176 divided by 4 what
does that come out to that's 44 okay but
a lot of times what students will do is
they'll say okay the answer is 44 but
remember it's asking us what's the
measure of angle yxz we have to put that
back in here 44 in place of X that's 44
plus 12 so it's actually going to be 56
degrees so don't make that mistake if
you do the algebra make sure you're
answering that what they're asking for
okay now number six it says if a pair of
complementary angles have measures of 3x
+ 2 + 5 X - 8 find the measure of the
two angles okay now what they're testing
a sign on this problem is do we know the
definition complementary and
supplementary complementary means the
angles add up to 90 right and
supplementary means they add up to 180
in this case if they're complementary
all we have to do is add them together
and set them equal to 90 degrees okay so
we're going to combine like terms that
comes out to 8x minus 6 equals 90 add
the 6 to the other side divide
everything by 8 so we get x equals 12
but again remember just like the
previous problem we have to put 12 back
in that's going to be 3 times 12 is 36
plus 2 is 38 and if we put 12 in here we
get 60 minus 8 which is 52 and if you
want to double check yourself if you add
these together you can see they add up
to 90 so we know we're on the right
track now number 7 it says if a polygon
has seven sides name the polygon now
it's kind of funny because seven sides
question number seven right okay so what
does the name of a polygon that has
seven sides well this one sometimes
students forget it's a heptagon okay
heptagon remember six sides is a hex
five is a Pentagon four is a
quadrilateral three is a triangle what's
8 octagon nine nonagon it kind of sounds
like 910 decagon like 10 years in a
decade ok but in this case seven sides
heptagon that's the one you want to ok
question number 8 they give us this
triangle here and it says find the
perimeter find the area okay so you
probably member this from your
pre-algebra class but remember perimeter
is the distance all the way around the
object and so what you would do is you
would add up 7 plus 8 plus 5 and that
comes up to 20 and whatever the units
are it's just going to be the units if
it's centimeters at centimeters if it's
inches it's inches in this case it
doesn't write the unit so I'm just going
to write units now the area what they're
testing us on of course is the formula
for the area of a triangle in which you
want to memorize is 1/2 base times
height so the base is the bottom that's
what the triangle sits on the height is
the perpendicular distance so you don't
want to accidentally use 7 or 8 you want
to use this perpendicular height that's
the shortest distance from the vertex to
the base ok so that's 6 so what we have
is we have 5 times 6 times 1/2 so let's
write that down 1/2 of 5 times 6 that's
30 half of 30 is 15 but here what you
want is unit squared okay so for area
it's 2-dimensional and you're trying to
fill it up with 1 by 1 squares okay now
number 9 if they're giving us a circle
and it says what's the radius of the
circle what's the circumference of the
circle ok so again they're testing us on
some basic formulas here but remember
the radius is the distance from the
center to any point on the edge of the
circle so it's like a spoke of a wheel
but what they're giving us here is the
diameter 12 inches we have to cut that
in half so the radius is going to be 6
inches now the circumference is a fancy
name for the perimeter of a circle it's
the distance all the way around and we
want to remember this formula for
circumference it's 2 pi R 2 times pi
times the radius or you can say since 2
times the radius is the diameter so you
double the radius is the diameter you
could say pi times diameter so since
they give us the diameter is 12 it's
just going to be 12 times pi and that's
an exact answer but you could put 3.14
in 4 pi and then you know use that as an
approximation so I'm just going to say
12 PI inches
okay so a couple formulas to memorize
one-half base times height and
circumference okay for number ten excuse
me it says given the sequence negative
714 negative 28 56 describe the pattern
and write the next term you know in the
pattern now you might be saying yourself
well it doesn't seem a lot like you know
geometry and they throw this hatch in in
your geometry class but what this is
really testing on is inductive reasoning
so can you follow a pattern can you you
know making a conjecture about what the
next point you know the next sub figure
is in the pattern and so on well you can
see so in this case the pattern it looks
like what we're doing is we're
multiplying by negative two each time so
that would be the pattern the next term
would be 56 times negative 2 which is
going to be negative 112 okay so again
that's inductive reasoning as opposed to
deductive reasoning which you're going
to be doing when you get into the proofs
you're using the laws of logic and etc
now number 11 it says the product of two
numbers is always greater than the
larger number so here it says what kind
of a statement is this the product of
two numbers is always greater than the
larger number well this is called a
conjecture and I actually definitely set
it over here when we were doing that
problem but conjecture it's basically
like you know you're making an educated
gas based on the facts and figures that
you have and it's not proven though you
know we're just making this conjecture
saying well you know this is what I
think it is now is this true or false
well okay remember product means you're
multiplying or timesing the two numbers
together and when you multiply two
numbers together is it always greater
than the larger number well you know
let's take an example let's say for
example 1/2 times 16 we know that equals
8 right but 8 is not larger than 16 so
this is false okay so we showed an
example where it's false and you know
this says if false give a counter
example so this is our counter example
it basically shows where it doesn't work
so you can't really prove something by
giving example after example after
example but you can disprove it by
showing one example you know at minimum
where it doesn't work and that's enough
to say hey you know something's not
right with this conjecture you know must
be false and
back to the drawing board right and then
letter C says rewrite as a conditional
statement okay so a lot of definitions
here but conditional statement is
basically what it's an if-then statement
right it's saying if the hypothesis
right if the hypothesis happens then the
conclusion will occur
so it's an if-then statement so how
could we rewrite this so if you multiply
two numbers together okay then the
product will be greater than the larger
number so see I switched it from it just
a statement like this into an if this
happens then this will happen so if you
multiply two numbers together then the
result will be greater than the larger
numbers if then so that's conditional
okay question number 12 says two parts
it says if it's knows more than a foot
then the schools will close and it says
if school is closed then the tests will
be moved back a day so we've got two
different conditional statements and it
asks us what is the contrapositive of
statement one okay and then it also asks
what's the converse of statement number
two okay so what we want to go through
really quick here are the different
types of statement so we've got a
conditional statement which looks like
this if P then Q right so this is the
hypothesis this is the conclusion the
converse is like this you reverse them
if Q then P right so it's like saying it
backwards or in reverse and then the
inverse is where you negate the
hypothesis and conclusion but you keep
them in the same order that's called the
inverse and then the contrapositive is a
combination of the converse and the
inverse you switch the hypothesis and
conclusion and you negate them both so
that's what these symbols mean here so
it's a quick way over just remembering
so you have conditional converse inverse
and contrapositive so what I like to do
is whatever comes after the if I like to
underline that's the hypothesis whatever
comes after the then I like to underline
that's the conclusion so this is like
our P this is like our Q and so if we
say what's the contrapositive we have to
switch these and negate them
so what the contrapositive would be it
would be if the school's I'm just
abbreviating here because we only have a
little bit of room so if the
fools don't close so you do not i'm
negating it if they don't close right
then what happens then it did not snow
more than a foot then it did not snow
did not snow greater I'll just say
greater than one foot okay so you
understand what we did so we switch the
hypothesis and conclusion we didn't
Gaeta them both now for the converse of
statement number two it says if school
is closed then the tests will be moved
back a day so again what I like to do is
underline whatever comes after the if
that's the hypothesis whatever comes
after the then that's the conclusion
right and so the conference is like
saying it backwards so we're switching
them we're saying if the tests will be
moved back a day then school is closed
now it doesn't necessarily mean that
just because we can write these
statements that they're true okay so the
converse is not necessarily true you
have to test it out but basically what
all I'm doing is I'm just switching it
so I'm saying if the test okay is move
back a day moved back
I'm just abbreviating right then right
school school was closed right school
was closed alright so that's how you
work with those so let's look at number
thirteen so it says name the following
properties so here we're getting into
some of the properties if a b is equal
to b c then b c equals a b which
property is that notice all we did was
we switched the a b and the bc like that
well that's called the symmetric
property so you want to memorize that so
when you change the order it's like it's
like a line of symmetry you can fold
over that line of symmetry it's the same
saying it forward or backwards measure
of angle a equals a measure of angle a
well obviously anything can be equal to
itself right but what's that called well
that's called the reflexive property and
you can remember that it's like looking
in a mirror you're the same height in
the mirror as you are in real life
right unless it's like some kind of a
convex or not a flat mirror right okay
so reflexive anything is equal to itself
and then the third one here it says if a
B equals
BC and BC equals DF then a B is equal to
DF so what property is that it's kind of
like if I'm as tall as you are and
you're as tall as your brother then I'm
as tall as your brother so what what is
that that's called the transitive
property all right it's like a train
it's like the first is connected to the
second the second is connected to the
third the first is connected to the last
or the third okay so that's the
transitive property so symmetric
reflexive transitive we use these a lot
in geometry so definite review those
okay now number fourteen we're starting
to get into proofs a little bit here and
they start off by giving us an algebra
proof something that you did you know
solving an algebra equation last year in
algebra but now we're actually
justifying the steps so what we're doing
is we're writing this has a two column
proof this is the statements on the Left
this these are the reasons on the right
sometimes they call them the
justifications you know but we're just
gonna say statements and reasons now the
first statement is you usually write
this first it's the get it okay they're
going to tell you something that's true
some type of starting point something
that you can assume is true and then
what they'll tell you what to prove okay
and then that's usually going to be your
last statement but we have to do is we
have to fill in the in-between
statements to tied it together right so
let's take a look so if you were solving
this in algebra what would you do well
first thing I would do is I'd probably
go like so all right so what did I do
well you can see I distributed the two
so I'm just going to write step number
two and I'm just going to say that's the
distributive property just I'm just
going to abbreviate distributive
property okay then what's the next step
what would you do if you were solving
well you probably would do something
like this right so what's that called
why would just call that simplifying or
combining like terms so I'll just say
combine like terms alright okay now how
about number step number four step
number four I probably would let's see
I'm going to see if you can figure out
what I'm doing here so okay so what you
can see here is I did I subtracted the
3x from both sides and I let's see I
subtracted the negative eight from both
sides so as long as you do it
both sides that's called property of
equality in this case it's the
subtraction property of equality so I'm
just going to write subtraction property
of equality
I'm just abbreviating okay so then the
last step is what okay we've got our
answer and that you can see I divided
both sides by negative 9 so that's
called the division property of equality
so that's an algebra proof and we know
how to solve algebra equations again but
the only thing that's different now in
geometry is we're actually justify or
giving the reasons why we can go from
one step to the next step to the next
step
generally like I said we start with the
Givens usually we end up with what we're
trying to prove as the last step and
we're just trying to fill in the
intermediate or in-between steps ok so
that's an introduction they're two
proofs now number 15 it says I give us
this rectangular prism here and it says
name a line that's skew to line H G so
where's line H G so that's this line
right here
okay and what does it mean when two
lines are skewed well we know what it
means when two lines are parallel right
parallel means that the two lines are in
the same plane right same plane means
the same like flat surface and they
don't cross they don't intersect but
what skew lines mean are like here's one
line like this like my my arm
and here's another line going like this
now they don't cross but you can see
they're in two different planes you know
it's like one is up here right and let's
say maybe like one is uh kind of like
over here like this right so here's a
line here's a line okay and in this case
it looks like they actually would cross
okay but that that's not the best
example so like let's take a look over
here in this diagram
so where's two lines that are in two
different planes two different flat
surfaces but they don't cross well okay
I'm gonna extend line each G a little
bit so you can see a little bit better
okay but you see this line here like
c.b.c this is like over here on the left
side of the box this is on the right
side of the box even if I extend this
line up and down and I extend this one
over here like so these are never going
to cross it's like two airplanes it's
like why don't planes crash in the air
well once at this altitude ones at this
altitude they're not going to cross
because they're at two different you
know heights basically two different
planes and so that's one example you
could also use line ad
see what you wouldn't want to do is do a
chi these would cross at point H you
wouldn't want to do line EF because
these are actually parallel they're not
crossing but they're in the same flat
surface you could do line DF that would
work okay
so there's a lot of correct answers for
that one and then Part B says name a
plane that's perpendicular to plane hg
hg a is the front of this rectangular
prism the front of this box we want it
to be perpendicular meaning it forms a
right angle so a good example here would
be let's see hg a is the front we could
do me the base of the box so we could do
plane ADF for example ADF okay but here
what we're doing instead of talking
about perpendicular lines right forming
right angles we're talking about
perpendicular planes something like
something like this right see if I can
draw this here for us see they're
forming a right angle the two planes
okay so that's a little bit about
talking about skew lines parallel lines
perpendicular lines if you're enjoying
this course and you like my teaching
style and you want to prepare for the a
CT math section or the SAT math section
check out my two huge review courses
once for the SAT math section once for
the a CT math section so we have a
teaching section there's example
problems we go through formulas we go
through different types of problems like
you would see on the test and talk about
how to approach them how to solve them
so check out the three free previews
that I have available for each of those
two courses if you're interested a lot
of students have taken them and reported
back that they've improved their scores
and so I hope that you'll take advantage
of that as well and if you're interested
in online tutoring with me you can
contact me I'll have a link for that if
you want to do some facetiming or if you
want to use the shared whiteboard that i
use when i work with students online via
Skype we can do that as well so let's
get continuing with this video though
question number 16 this is a really
important concept you've got two lines
and again in this case M and N and
they're cut by a third line which is
called a transversal and you can see in
the process there's e angles that are
formed so really important concept for
geometry and it says classify the angles
meaning you know are they corresponding
or they alternate interior are they
vertical and so on so let's see angle 1
and angle 4
well when you have two lines that cross
like this or they form an X the angles
that are across from each other either
these two or these two those are called
vertical angles and if the two lines are
basically like this they're going to be
congruent or equal to each other it's
like a pair of scissors right so in this
case we're going to say vertical angles
okay
angle 1 and angle 8 ok so angle 1 and
angle 8 these are actually called
alternate because see how ones on the
left side of this transversal ones on
the right but they're outside of these
two lines like this that's called
exterior so 1 and 8 are called alternate
exterior I'm just going to abbreviate a
alternate exterior angle 4 and angle 5
okay now these again ones on the right
ones on the left but now they're in
between those two lines so this is
called alternate interior ok and then
let's see 5 & 6 so 5 & 6 you see how
they form a line like that and they're
right next to each other that's called a
linear pair and these are going to be
supplementary these are going to add up
to 180 degrees like a straight angle so
I'm just going to write LP for linear
pair now angle 4 and angle 6 notice how
these are on the same side of this
transversal okay and they're in between
the two lines M and N so those are
called consecutive interior consecutive
like one after another interior meaning
in between the two lines so don't get
those confused you've got alternate
interior like 3 & 6 4 & 5 consecutive
interior is like 4 & 6 & 3 & 5 now let's
look at angle 3 and angle 7 so 3 & 7 a
lot of times students mix this one up
these are called corresponding angles
basically you see how this forms like an
X and you see how this forms like an X
if I pick this X up and I place it on
top of that X the angles that match up
with one another they correspond those
are called a corresponding angles so you
have like upper left hand corner upper
left hand corner upper right upper right
lower right lower right and so on they
correspond or match up so I'm just going
to write corresponding angles will just
write corresponding angles okay and then
let's see letter G says if m and n are
parallel now notice here we didn't even
say anything about the lines being
parallel and you can still classify them
like we did but if line m and n are
and angle six is seventy degrees so
let's just put that in here seventy
degrees find the measure of angle three
and the measure angle four well angle
three that's an alternate interior angle
that's going to be congruent with angle
six so that's going to be seventy
degrees angle four on the other hand
this is a consecutive interior angle
sometimes they call it a same side
interior because it's on the same side
of the transversal these two angles are
supplementary so in this case this angle
would be 110 degrees so just a quick
review alternate exterior are going to
be congruent alternate interior are
going to be congruent vertical angles
are congruent corresponding angles are
congruent the ones that are
supplementary are the ones that form a
linear pair or the ones that are
consecutive interior like four and six
three and five now what's interesting
about this diagram I'll just make one
last note about this is that when you
have two lines that are parallel cut by
a transversal let's just say this angle
here is 120 what you'll notice is that
all the obtuse angles are 120 all the
acute angles in this case are 60 so even
though that we have eight angles total
there's only two angle measurements okay
60 and 120 in this case so very
important concept so let's go to number
17 it says find the value of x that
makes line m and n I'm sorry m and P
parallel so what do these values of X
have to be so that these two lines are
parallel now what we're talking about
right now is these two angles are
corresponding angles see lower left-hand
corner lower left-hand corner here we
talked about picking up that X and
placing on that X the only way that
these two lines will be parallel if the
corresponding angles are congruent so
this is called the corresponding angles
converse theorem because we're saying it
backwards in order to prove line m in
our M and P are parallel so we have to
set these equal to each other this is
just a little bit of algebra but the key
thing is to make sure you know that
they're congruent and not supplementary
so let's go ahead and subtract 4x from
both sides let's add 2 to both sides
divide by 2 you can see that x equals 6
and we got it okay now number 4 18 it
says a line passes through the point 2
negative 8 and 4 6 find an equation of
the line in slope intercept form ok now
remember slope intercept
is y equals MX plus B so it feels a
little bit like we're going back to
Algebra one but this is also part of
geometry and so what we're going to do
is we're going to find our slope which
is M and remember the slope formula is
the difference in the Y values over the
difference in the X values so I'm going
to take negative 8 minus 6 over 2 minus
4 and you want to keep that order
consistent I did I 2 minus y1 over x2
minus x1 so that's negative 14 over
negative 2 which gives us the slope of 7
so we've got y equals 7x plus B I just
put the 7 in for M right there but now
to solve for B what do we do well we
take one of these points I'm just going
to take this point here I'm going to put
six in for Y since that's the
y-coordinate 4 in for X and I'm going to
solve for B so what do we get we get 28
mmm okay and if I subtract 28 that gives
us negative 22 equals B and what we can
do is we can put that back in for B
right here so y equals 7x minus 22 and
you got it ok number 19 it says here's
line 1 it goes through these two points
here's lying 2 it goes through these two
points are the lines parallel
perpendicular or neither this is a
common question definitely something you
want to remember but the way we figure
out the lines are parallel is if they
have the same slope because they're
going up at the same angle that's why
they don't cross but if they're
perpendicular meaning they form a right
angle to one another like this okay 90
degrees then the slopes are what we call
opposite reciprocals like if one is
three halves the other one will be
negative 2/3 so the sign flips and the
fraction flips okay so let's go ahead
and figure out what these slopes are so
6 minus 4 is 2 3 minus negative 2 is 5
so this is line 1 1 minus 6 is negative
5 3 minus 1 is positive 2 okay when we
look at these two slopes you can see
they're opposite signs once positive one
is negative and they're reciprocals of
one another so I flip one of them over
to get the other one so that means that
these lines are actually going to be
perpendicular they form a right angle so
that's going to be the best answer for
that one now if they were both true
fists then they would be parallel and
then if it was like 2/5 and 3 for
example then that's neither they're
going to cross but not at a right angle
ok question
4:28 if you're enjoying this video and
it's helping you you know make sure to
give this video a thumbs up that will
let me know to make more midterm reviews
and final exam reviews like this for you
guys
so number 20 says write an equation of
the line through this point and parallel
to this line okay so what they're asking
us here is you know do we know how to
write the equation of a line do we know
what it means for lines to be parallel
and remember when you have parallel
lines what do we know we know that they
have the same slope but they don't
necessarily have the same y-intercept so
I'm just making the y-intercept here the
B value just as B now if we want it to
be parallel and we know goes through
this point negative 2 1 let's put the y
coordinate 1 in for y and let's put the
x coordinate negative 2 in for X and we
just have to solve for B now now a lot
of times students get a little bit
stumped here when you have a fraction in
a whole number where the key is to make
that whole number into a fraction by
putting it over 1 so what you have here
is you multiply the numerators and
denominators together that's negative 6
over 2 which is negative 3 so now we
have one equals negative 3 plus B add
the 3 to the other side and you can see
that B equals 4 we just have to put 4
back in here for B and you got it so y
equals 3 halves X plus 4 that's the
equation of your line parallel to the
given line but it goes through this
particular point okay now number 21 it
says find the value of x and classify
the triangle okay now what they're
testing is that in this problem is do we
understand that all the angles in a
triangle add up to how much 180 right so
all we have to do is write an equation
so we've got X plus 3 X plus 1 plus 43
equals 180 so X plus 3 X that's 4 X 1
and 43 that's 44 equals 180
subtract the 44 from both sides that
gives us how much 136 and divide by 4
how much is that well let's see that's
is it 39 let's see 34 ok 34 so then what
we want to do so X is 34 degrees and if
we put 34 back in that means that this
angles 34 3 times 34 is how much well
let's see that's 90 that's 102
two plus one that's a hundred and three
right yeah so it's 103 so basically if
we want to classify this triangle now
because one of the angles is more than
90 that means that this is an obtuse
triangle if there are all less than 90
would be an acute triangle if two the
angles are the same it would be a
isosceles triangle if they were all the
same angle like all 60 degrees then it
would be an equilateral triangle or an
equiangular triangle okay you can use
either because we're both but in this
case we're going to say it's an obtuse
triangle okay because one of the angles
is more than 90 okay now number 22 says
classify the triangle by its sides okay
by its side lengths here we classified
it by its angle measures so here you can
see that there's two sides that are the
same so that means that this is going to
be an isosceles triangle if all the side
lengths are different it's going to be
scalene okay if they're all the same
it's equilateral okay if they're all
different its scalene if they're all the
same it's equilateral if two are the
same its isosceles right so two
different names one by the angles and
one by the number of you know by the
side lengths okay number 23 now they
give us this diagram here and it says
find the measure of angle one two and
three okay so it's kind of like a puzzle
right or like a maze or something you're
trying to solve here but remember we
know that all angles add up to 180 and
we learned that you know vertical angles
are congruent linear pairs those two
angles add up to 180 and so on so let's
see if we can work our way through this
diagram this little square here means 90
okay so I'm just going to pencil that in
if this is 120 see how these two angles
form a line they're a linear pair that
means this is 60 and you can see that 90
plus 60 is 150 which means angle 3 is 30
okay so we figure that one out and then
let's see what else we have if this is
120 this is 60 or you can see that these
are vertical angles because they form
that X the angles that are crossing each
other are congruent right let's see what
else do we know well we know that this
is 90 and 60 that's 150 which means that
angle 1 must be 30 okay good and now we
know this is 15
okay so angle 1 is 30 let's put that in
here and then if this is 15 in 120
that's 135 that means that angle 2 must
be 45 because all three of these angles
have to add up to 180 degrees in a
triangle right so that's what you do is
you work through your diagram like that
and I use
like to write right on the diagram so I
don't have to remember you know what the
measures are I can just kind of look at
the diagram as I go through it and just
work through it
so number 24 find the measure of angle a
now you want to look at the diagram for
hints or clues and notice that they show
us that these two sides have the same
markings that means that they're
congruent or they're the same length
that means it's an isosceles triangle
and the important things to remember
about isosceles triangles are that the
base angles are the angles that are
across from those congruent sides okay
these are called the base angles these
are congruent so that means that we can
set these equal to each other so if we
do that let's make an equation here 2x
plus 5 equals 3x minus 10 subtract the
3x from both sides that's negative 1x
subtract the 5 from both sides that's
negative 15 multiply both sides by
negative 1 we get X is 15 but it says
find the measure of angle a again we
have to put that back in 2 times 15 is
30 plus 5 is 35 degrees okay so you're
with me so far so do the algebra but
make sure you answer the question
sometimes you have to put it back in now
number 25 a and B it's asking us are
these two triangles congruent are these
two triangles congruent now remember
there's five different ways to prove
triangles congruent that we learned in
geometry what are the five different
ways you can remember them there's side
side side meaning that three sides in
one triangle are congruent to three
sides in the other we've got side angle
side okay we've got angle side angle
we've got angle angle side and we've got
hypotenuse leg that's when we have a
right triangle and a right triangle the
hypotenuse is are the same and one of
the legs and one triangle is congruent
to one of the legs in the other triangle
so let's see what we have here now they
give us clues and that's what you want
to look for you they already tell us
that these sides are the same gay by
this marking they tell us that this line
is parallel to this line and what I like
to do is extend those lines and you can
even extend the transversal like that so
it looks more like that diagram we were
working with earlier in the in the
review and now we can see is that these
angles are going to be congruent okay
because they're alternate interior
angles okay remember this diagram right
alternate interior and then we know that
they share this side okay this side is
shared between the two triangles so now
look what we've got we've got
side angle side side angle side okay so
these two triangles are congruent and we
can prove that using the side angle side
triangle congruence theorem okay now
over here again they also show us that
these lines are parallel so we could
extend these two lines if you want we
notice that vertical angles the angles
that are crossing each other when they
two lines cross like in that X formation
those are going to be congruent we know
that these angles are going to be
congruent by alternate interior these
are also congruent by alternate interior
you might be tempted to say angle angle
angle now whether you can see angle
angle angle is not one of the triangle
congruence theorems that we have so we
can't actually prove that these
triangles are congruent they're similar
meaning that one triangle might be you
know proportional to the other you know
they might be exactly the same it might
be a one-to-one proportion but we can't
prove that we know that they're similar
meaning that the corresponding is
they're congruent but the corresponding
sides are proportional but we can't
prove that if I cut this out and match
it up with that one it's going to be an
exact match at the congruence so in this
case can't prove it no this one yes side
angle side definitely important concept
you want to review these triangle
congruence theorems okay question number
26 or is everyone picking up some good
pointers on their geometry midterm
review I hope so so let's see so to
prove that BC is congruent to da so this
segment is congruent to this segment
what would you prove first okay that's a
good question okay so you know a lot of
times on a midterm exam they don't have
time to have you prove like all these
proofs you know so they just try to pick
out little bits and pieces of a proof so
they can kind of test you on multiple
concepts within a given time frame so
basically if we wanted to show that this
segment is congruent to the segment I
notice that these Chinese two lines are
parallel not necessarily congruent
ideally what I want to do is show that
this triangle is congruent to this
triangle then by the CPC I'll for the
cpct see the corresponding parts of
congruent triangles are congruent there
we can show that those parts are
congruent but how do we prove these two
triangles are congruent well first of
all when two triangles share a side like
that you know that BD is congruent to BD
by the reflexive property so anything's
be congruent to itself also we know that
this angle angle ADB is congruent to
this angle DBC by alternate interior
angles okay because these are two
parallel lines cut by a transversal but
I think what they're looking for in this
problem is show that triangle triangle
ADB a d B is congruent to triangle let's
see what that would be CBD triangle CBD
and that's by the angle angle side
triangle congruence theorem so angle
angle side remember the five side side
side side angle side and so on but angle
angle side once we know the triangles
are congruent then by cpctc or some
books use cpcf the corresponding parts
of congruent figures will be congruent
now let's go to question number 27 so
they give us these three coordinates
okay and I've plotted them here for us
and it says let's see what does it say
the coordinates of B Prime
find the coordinates of B prime after
reflection over the line y equals x now
remember the line y equals x is a
45-degree line like that but when you
reflect over that line what happens is
this is the formula that you want to
memorize is that coordinates a B become
ba they actually interchange and you can
see let's see where's Point a it's one
zero now you can see it's going to be
over here at zero one so we're basically
reflecting or folding over that line you
can see that point is going to match up
with zero comma one so I've got a whole
video talking about rotations
reflections and the rules but here
reflection over the line y equals x you
switch the X and the y coordinates okay
now for the second part it wants us to
find out what's the rotation of this
triangle 90 degrees okay and I should
have specified counterclockwise so going
this direction 90 degrees about the
origin okay so the thing that we want to
know here are how do you rotate points a
and B 90 degrees well it's going to be a
nag
B comma a so what you do is you switch
the X and the y coordinates you make the
new x-coordinate the opposite sign okay
so if we do that let's switch them first
that might be a little bit easier so 0 1
1 4 3 2 and then we're going to make the
new x-coordinate the opposite of course
opposite of 0 is still going to be 0 so
I'll just leave it like that now if we
plot those points you can see that 0 1
is here negative 1 4 is going to be
right about here and negative 3 2 is
going to be right about there so honor
if you can see this but you're turning
it 90 degrees about this point
okay so again review that video if you
want to review how to do the rotation so
I'll give you another example like if
you rotate 180 degrees a B would become
negative a negative B so that they stay
in the same order but you just make them
the opposite sign if you rotate 270
degrees counterclockwise a B becomes B
negative 8 so you switch the X and the y
and you make the new y-coordinate the
opposite sign so those are four
rotations reflections are a little bit
easier if you reflect over the y-axis
what happens is a B just becomes
negative a B so the x coordinates the
ops if you reflect over the x-axis like
this way then you have a b goes to a
negative b so this was a this is
reflecting over the y this is reflecting
over the x okay so definitely review
those formulas it's very important okay
now number 28 if segment su is a mid
segment of triangle RVT find the length
of RV when they don't put a bar over it
that just means the length of our visa
distance between R and V and this is
called the mid-segment theorem and
basically what it means is if this is a
mid segment it's connecting the midpoint
of this side to the midpoint of this
side and this is going to be parallel to
the base the mid segment and it's going
to be half of the base which means that
the base is going to be double so this
is going to be 24 so that's the
mid-segment theorem okay number 29 it
says given this rectangle WXYZ find the
coordinates of point W okay so this is
like what they call a coordinate proof
or a coordinate type problem but they
tell us it's a rectangle we
these are 90-degree angles we know that
the you know opposite sides are
congruent and so what we have to figure
out is okay how do we find the according
to this point well for going right a
okay comma zero so this this length here
is a here you're going left a so this
distance is a gave it negative because
you're going to the left here see this
is a B you're going to write a up B so
that means this height of the rectangle
is B that means this would also be B so
to get to this point we have to go left
a so negative a up B that's positive B
so the coordinates of point W would be
negative a B okay question number 30
they give us this diagram here and it
says if line L okay which is this
horizontal line here is the
perpendicular bisector of segment a B
okay find C B this length right here so
what they're testing us on in this
problem is the perpendicular bisector
theorem do we know what the
perpendicular bisector theorem is what
the perpendicular bisector theorem tells
us is that if you have a line segment
like this and you draw a perpendicular
and it bisects that meaning meaning it
cuts it in half if you pick any point
along this line say for example right
here what do you know about the distance
to this end point in the distance to
this end point well they're going to be
congruent and the reason is is because
you see how they share the side by the
reflexive property these two triangles
are going to be congruent by side angle
side side angle sides so by cpctc the
corresponding parts of congruent
triangles are congruent so that's what
we have here we have a perpendicular
bisector therefore we know that CAS
convert to CB we just have to do the
algebra now set the two segments equal
to each other and we see that x equals 8
and wants to know the length of CB which
is right here we just have to put it
back in that's 24 plus 7 which is 31
okay so that's the perpendicular
bisector theorem so review that one if
you need to hear what they're testing us
on is the angle bisector theorem we've
got two angles that are congruent which
means that this ray here DB okay is an
angle bisector it's cutting this angle
in half but just a quick review on the
angle bisector theorem what it tells us
is if we have an angle and we bisect it
and we cut it
half if we pick a point anywhere along
this ray okay and we measure the
perpendicular distance to the sides of
the angle then those lengths are going
to be congruent to each other okay and
the way I like to explain it is if
you're going down a river and it's
getting wider and wider but you stay to
the center of the river you fall out of
your canoe or your boat should you swim
to the shore or to this shore well it
shouldn't really matter right because
you're right in the middle but the thing
is is when you measure the distance from
a point to a line you always want to
measure that perpendicular distance
that's a the shortest distance okay and
again you can prove this because if
these angles are congruent and they
share the side between the two triangles
by the angle-angle-side
triangle congruence theorem by cpctc you
can show that these two lengths are the
same okay but to make a long story short
here we don't know that BC and ba are
perpendicular to the sides of this angle
so we really don't all by mean this
might be 90 it might be 80 90 degrees we
don't know even though this is an angle
bisector we can't show that ba is
congruent to BC there's not enough
information okay so that's a little bit
of a trick question there number 32 it
says finding the centroid of the
triangle the vertices given now what's
the centroid well centroid it's
basically like the center of mass like
it's the point where if you were to cut
that triangle out and balance it at that
point it would be perfectly balanced
okay it's like the center of gravity
center of mass and basically all it is
is like an average you add the
x-coordinates together and you divide by
three not two like the midpoint it's
three since you have three points so
let's do that negative two plus three is
1 plus 8 is 9 divided by 3 equals 3 and
then 6 plus 4 is 10 minus plus a
negative 4 it would be 6 and 6 divided
by 3 equals 2 so our centroid is going
to be at 3 2 okay that's the center of
mass so just like an average add up the
x-coordinate divided by 3 at the
y-coordinate which angle is the largest
okay so they give us this triangle here
now remember when we talk about angles
we're basically thinking about hinges
right and angles like a hinge okay like
a door hinge and when you look at the
side that's the longest if you look
across from that side that's going to be
the largest angle
and then the one across from the
shortest side okay like that that's
going to be the smallest angle and then
of course the medium across from the
medium side so it's like a hinge in
order to open up to the widest side like
that the angle across has to be the
largest so in this case Ingleby is what
we're looking for here and vice versa if
we knew that angle B was the largest
angle 130 degrees say for example across
from that angle would be the longest
side okay number 34 says if a triangle
has side lengths of 7 and 3 what is an
interval for the length of the third
side okay so this is a very good
question so the thing is is that let me
see if I can show you with an example
here like grab grab some some props here
okay so here we've got this marker and
here we've got this eraser and you can
see this is like a hinge okay so you can
you can rotate this right so for example
if we have seven like this and three
like this see the longest that this
third side would be is if you open it up
at a 180 degree angle like this so if
this was seven and this is three the
longest that that third side would have
to stretch would be 210 right so we're
going to put ten over here okay and then
the small so would be is if we rotate
this down like this okay then it would
only have to span from here to here okay
so let's see if I can draw that so
here's seven here's three going back
this direction right now it only has to
span from here to here that length is
going to be four now it can't be exactly
four it it can't be exactly ten because
if it was exactly ten this would be
actually fold flat okay and same thing
here if this was exactly 4 this would be
folding flat so we want some space in
there to actually form a triangle so as
long as you're in between 4 and 10 not
including 4 and 10 that's the range or
the interval for the length of that
third side now for number 35 it says
kind of triangle be made with side
lengths of 3 6 and 9 okay now this is
testing us on the triangle inequality
theorem just like with the last problem
but the thing that you want to check is
it when you add any two sides up they
always have to be greater than the third
side so again 3 & 6 that adds up to 9
that's not greater than 9 okay so let's
look an example of another triangle like
see if you had a triangle like 5 6 & 7
see 12 is greater than 6 13 is greater
than 5 well happens greater than 7 and
so on
that forms a triangle but here are three
plus six is nine nine is not greater
than nine it's it's not it's equal to
nine it's not greater than nine so in
this case you can't form a triangle like
that it would actually be the scenario
where it's lying flat you've got nine
here's six here's three it just barely
reaches but it's compressing flat so
can't make a triangle with those three
sides okay question number 36 they give
us these two triangles here and it says
given that EC okay this length is
greater than DF this length solve for
possible values of X okay so here are
what they're testing a sign is notice
that these two sides are congruent to
these two sides but they're telling us
that this side is greater than this side
so basically think about taking you know
to two line sight segments say like this
marker in this orange pencil right and
if this third side right here is longer
okay what happens to this angle well you
can see it's actually becoming larger so
basically we know that 6x minus 8 has to
be greater than 4x plus 12 okay so all I
have to do now is solve this I'll
subtract 4x from both sides I'm going to
add 8 to both sides divide by 2 as long
as X is greater than 10 okay we know
that this angle is going to be larger
than this angle which means that this
side is gonna be longer than this side
okay up up until a point obviously
because you know we don't want this
angle to be you know more than 180 and
would even form a triangle and so on but
basically as long as it's greater than
10 that's going to make this larger than
this angle it's going to open wider
right okay now number 37 it says the
angles in a triangle are in the extended
ratio okay so they're talking about
extended ratios here one two two two
three okay there's a little bit of a
trick to this problem it says find the
measures of the angles but once you see
it you know you've got it okay and the
key is is that you know just say here's
our generic triangle say this is 1 2 3
right what you want to do is you want to
add a variable in there like for example
X 1 X 2 2 X - 3 X that's still in the
ratio 1 2 2 2 3 right but in a triangle
all the angles add up to how much 180
right so 1
plus two x plus three x equals 180 now
we have an equation we can solve for X
so 6x equals 180 divided by 6 you can
see x equals 30 and by putting 30 back
in here I get 2 times 30 is 60 3 times
30 is 90 1 times 30 is 30 so these
angles are enough there are 30 degrees
60 degrees and 90 degrees which is a 1
to 2 to 3 ratio so again the key with
extender ratios is to add an that
variable usually I use the letter X it
doesn't matter with letters and then you
know all the angles in a triangle up to
180 so you can write your equation okay
see with me on that one okay so for
number 38 now we're getting into some
proportions and it says which is not
true so if X divided by 2 equals 3
divided by Y we know that's true which
of these is not true okay so testing us
on the properties of proportions let's
look at the first one the first one you
can see they're taking the reciprocal of
the left side and they're taking the
reciprocal of the right side so yeah
that's that's true and the way you can
kind of check it is see if you cross
multiply see x times y is equal to 3
times 2 which is 6
same thing here see x times y equals 6
right so those are equivalent okay now
let's look at letter B now notice what
they're going letter B they're actually
interchanging the 3 and the 2 on the
diagonal okay which is perfectly fine
because when you cross multiply see x
times y equals 3 times 2 which is 6
we're getting the exact same thing so
these are good so I'm going to cross
those out those are true or looking for
which one's not true
let's look at this one over here now
this one tends to stumped students now
notice that it looks a little bit you
know quite a bit different than the
original one but notice what they're
doing is they're adding this denominator
2 to the numerator and they're adding
this Y the denominator to the numerator
but what I like to do is I like to split
this up into two fractions like this
okay so you follow me on this see x over
2 equals 3 over Y that's our original
equation but what's 2 over 2 that's 1
what's Y ever'one that's 1 it's like
adding 1 to both sides of the equation
you're keeping it balanced right you're
not changing it so these are actually
this is actually a true statement okay
if you add you know you have to take an
equation you add 1 to both sides it's
still going to be equivalent right okay
now the last one let's double check
we've got Y over 2 equals x over 3 what
do they do to get to that position well
it looks like they switch the the X and
the y and
they took the reciprocal so they kind of
combined to you know the kind of mixed
and match but notice when you cross
multiply here you get 3y equals 2x which
is nothing like x times y equals 6 so
here again just to quickly review so
with the letter D you would not be true
you can switch these on the diagonal
okay you can take the reciprocal both
sides and you can add the denominator to
the numerator as long as you do it on
both sides you're adding this
denominator the numerator this
denominator the numerator it's like
adding one to both sides so those are
the properties of proportions review
that if you need to
number 39 it says if the legend of a map
says that 2 inches equals 25 miles in
real life right how far on the map is a
distance of 175 miles in real life how
far would it be on the map right so
again talking about the theme of
proportions we've got two inches for
every 175 miles X inches for how I said
that wrongdoing two inches for every 25
miles right 25 miles X inches for a
hundred and seventy-five miles the key
here when you do proportions always
you're comparing apples to apples right
Oren just orangist
we've got map to real life map to real
life this ratio is the same as this
ratio so scale to actual scale to actual
I sometimes say it so when you cross
multiply this is the means extremes
property cross multiply 25 X right
equals 2 times 175 which is 350 divide
both sides by 25 and what does that come
out to is it 14
I think it's 14 let me double check real
quick 25
yep 14 so that's it so that it would be
14 inches on the map and remember when
you do your word problems or your story
problems you want to put your units
right okay so number 40 they give us
this triangle here notice they draw this
line here XR which is parallel to base Y
Z okay and so this is called the
triangle proportionality theorem or
sometimes we refer to as a
side-splitting theorem because see this
XR splits the sides of this two triangle
into two pieces right and so here's how
it works I'll just show you the you know
the property real quick so if this is
parallel to this you've got a
DCD the ratio of A to B is the same as
the ratio of C to D so this segment to
this segment equals this segment to this
segment as long as this line is parallel
to the base okay so that's what we're
going to do here to solve for XY I'm
just going to call this X okay for the
unknown so we've got six is 2x as five
is two to cross multiply we get 5x
equals 12
divide both sides by five we get x
equals 12 fifth and you got it if you're
enjoying this video and you like my
teaching style and you're preparing for
the a CT math section or the SAT math
section
check out my two video courses my huge
AC t-- math review video course and a
huge SAT math review video course
geometry pays a big role in both of
those tests I mean in addition to
algebra 1 algebra 2 pre algebra
trigonometry geometry is one of those
key pieces as well and we're going
through some of the concepts here but
there's additional concepts in that
course specifically focused on those two
tests so check out the three free
previews on both those courses to see if
it's a right fit for you a lot of
students have taken the courses already
and it boosted their scores and reported
back that it's really helped them so I'm
sure it will help you too but let's
continue on with this course also I
wanted to mention that if you're
preparing and you need some help with
some online tutoring them available for
online tutoring as well via FaceTime or
via Skype we can do either of those and
now we've got a shared whiteboard that
we can use in addition so reach out and
contact me if you're interested in that
otherwise let's keep going on with this
video here
number 41 what they're telling us as it
lines l m and n are all parallel so all
three these lines are parallel and
they're cut by two transversals like
that and it says find the length of each
I so I'll just call that length X now
this problem is very similar to the last
problem we did number 40 but when you
have three parallel lines cut by two
transversals let's just call these two
pieces a and B these two pieces C and D
the ratio of A to B is the same as C to
D so that's the that's the key formula
here so what we're going to do is we're
going to say 6 is to 8 right 6 is to 8
as 7 is to X okay and then all we have
to do is cross multiply 6x equals 56
divide both sides by 6 and so you can
see that's going to be
twenty-eight thirds okay so you're with
me on that one okay number 42 they give
us this triangle here and the bisect
this angle see how these two angles are
congruent and wants us to find X okay so
this is a angle bisector a theorem here
and what we have here is we have the
ratio of 2 is to 3 as X is to 7 you can
think of like taking this and folding it
over like so so 2 matches with 3 X
matches with 7 we make a proportion 2 is
2 3 as X is 2 7 cross multiply 3x equals
14 and divided by 3x equals 14 thirds
and you've got it okay number 43 it says
given that triangle d EF is similar now
to triangle GHI and I remember similar
means that the corresponding angles are
congruent but the corresponding sides
are proportional okay so they're in the
same ratio that says find the scale
factor from triangle d EF this one on
the left to triangle GHI this one on the
right and then Part B says find the
length of side x here hia okay now
here's the thing when you find the scale
factor what you want to do is if you're
going from the left to the right the
right one is the new one so the scale
factor it's the new divided by the old
okay so in this case if I'm going from 6
to 20 I'm going to take 20 divided by 6
and you can reduce that to 10 thirds
okay if I was going from the right one
to the left one then it would take 6
divided by 20 okay and you know you're
on the right track because if the scale
factor is greater than 1 it's an
enlargement the scale factor is smaller
than one it's going to be a reduction
okay it's getting smaller okay now the
second part says find X now this is a
little bit easier you just have to make
sure you're matching up the
corresponding sides so let's see I'm
running out of room here so let me see
if I can just put it right here so it
says 9 is 2 X k9 is 2 X as 6 is 220 then
all you have to do is cross multiply so
we have a 6x equals 180 so divided by 6
x equals 30 and you've got it so the key
here is when you're looking at a
similarity you want to make sure you're
matching up corresponding sides so see
how de is to G a
and EF is 2h I and D F is 2 G I so 1st
and 3rd matches up with 1st and 3rd so
that's how you can match up the
corresponding sides okay now number 44
it says are the triangles similar yes or
no and if they are right the similarity
statement ok now remember we talked
about proving triangles earlier there
was 5 ways right but to prove triangles
similar there's only three ways okay
there's the angle-angle similarity
there's the side-side-side similarity
and then there's a side angle side so
angle angle means that two angles in one
triangle are congruent to two angles in
another triangle and then automatically
the triangles are similar meaning the
corresponding sides are proportional
side side side we have to show that all
three sides in one triangle are in the
same ratio as three sides in another
triangle and in side angle side the two
sides have to be in the same ratio from
one triangle to the other but the angle
in between those two sides the included
angle has to be congruent and it has to
be the same so here when we look at this
overall triangle and this smaller
triangle you can see that they share
angle V okay see how they're like
overlapping at angle V so what we have
is this angle this angle are congruent
to this angle and this angle in the
larger triangle so yes they are indeed
similar and it's by the angle angle
similarity now to write the similarity
statement I'm going to say triangle ask
to you that's I'm sorry STV that's the
big triangle STV is similar to triangle
wwu V okay so you want to make sure
you're matching up the corresponding
angles and the corresponding sides and
number 45 says which triangles are
similar so they'll give us three
triangles here is it do G dot C 80 cat
or XYZ well what you want to do here and
I'll give you a little hint we're going
to do two at a time either these two or
these two or these two the key is you
want to match up the small side with the
small side medium with medium and
longest with longus okay so say I want
to compare these two sides here I'm
going to say short too short so that's
going to be three as to six okay
question mark is that the same as let's
see 4 is 2 8 4 is 2 8 as 5 is 2 11 we
can see 3 6 is 1/2 4 eighths is 1/2 5 11
not 1/2 they're not all in the same
ratio so these two are not similar let's
check the first and the third so I'm
going to compare short to short media
medium long too long so short too short
would be 3 to 9 right so 3 to 9 4 to 12
so medium to medium and longest to long
is so 5 to 15 oops 5 to 15 now if you
reduce these you get one-third one-third
one-third now they don't always reduce
perfectly so what you can just do is you
can get a decimal you can just divide 3
/ 9 4 / 12 5 divided by 15 you're going
to get point 3 3 3 3 4 all three of
these you can see that they're the same
so we know that the first and the third
are similar and then if you wanted to
write a similarity statement you would
just say well let's see this is how I
like to do it I like to trace it out so
I charts I'd medium side long side so
see how I went Oh DG o DG is similar to
triangle 2 let's do a short medium long
here so that would be X Z Y back to X so
X Z Y you don't have to do it that way
but I find it to be easier so you're
tracing short side medium side long side
and a same thing here short side medium
side long side that way you know you're
matching up the corresponding sides ok
last two questions so number 46 it says
determine if the triangles are similar
and if they are what is the scale factor
from figure 1 to figure 2 okay so it
looks like what they're giving us here
are two triangles one larger than the
other and it looks like they're going to
go society and angle an aside and the
angles in between the two sides so
remember there's three ways to prove
triangle similar that we learned angle
angle side side side and side angle side
and that's what we're focused on in this
problem is the side angle side technique
and so you can see that angles are
congruent okay so we got that let's
check that off the list let's compare
the corresponding sides now I want to
compare the longer one to the longer one
the shorter one to the shorter one so 8
is 2 2 okay 8 is 2 2 question mark as 12
is 2 3 so are those the same well 8
divided by 2 is 4 12 over 3 is 4 yes
that's true so the corresponding sides
are proportional and these triangles are
similar by the side angle side
similarity theorem okay but now it's
asking us what's the scale factor from
figure one to figure two now again like
we talked about in the previous problem
you want to take the new over the old
right so if you're going from 1 to 2 the
new length is going to be 3 the old
length is 12 so that's a scale factor of
1/4 which makes sense because 1/4 is
less than 1 it's shrinking it's it's a
reduction if we were going from here to
here it'd be an enlargement and it would
actually be the reciprocal of that scale
factor would be 4 over 1 so before
beginning a larger okay last question
says given segment a B with a - 8 and B
coordinates 1/4 find the coordinates of
point a this guy here after a dilation
of 5 halves centered about the origin ok
so what we're talking about now our
dilations ok so making it larger or
making it smaller and here's the thing
if you know point a is 2 8 you know the
scale factor is 5 halves all you have to
do is multiply the x-coordinate and the
y-coordinate by that scale factor so if
we do that
remember this is like anything divided
by 1 is itself so if I multiply the
numerators and dynamics to gether I get
10 divided by 2 which is 5 and here I
get 40 divided by 2 which is 20 so the
coordinates of the new point a prime
after that dilation of 5 halves 2.5
times larger these are going to be the
coordinates of point a so I hope this
video helps you to do better when you
take your geometry midterm exam or if
you're just reviewing your geometry
concepts I hope this helped you a lot so
subscribe to the channel check out more
geometry videos on my youtube channel
Mario's math tutoring and I look forward
to helping you in the future videos I'll
talk to you soon